[Music]
in the United States amid wild weather
and natural disasters climate change has
become a political battleground it is
time to exit the Paris Accord it really
comes down to the air that we breathe in
the water that we drank now it's a focus
of the 2020 election there's just a
person in the White House it is diluted
we can't read for him and the world
watches as one of the planets biggest
polluters makes its choice on a defining
issue of our time we have to fight for
this like it's life or death because it
is
New York congresswoman Alexandria Acacio
Cortez vilified by the right worshiped
by the left and the face of climate
change activism in American politics
[Applause]
she's pushing for a green new deal for
America a grand plan to stop using
fossil fuels and transform society in
the process it's become a crucial issue
for the Democrats in the 2020 race I'm
very encouraged by where a lot of the
candidates have gone in terms of the
scope and the size of their plans I
think that there is more room for the
whole field to be more ambitious because
for so long we were dealing with these
small piece meal plans as though they
were solutions like for example just a
carbon tax and I think that we've been
successful in shifting the scope and the
scale that people realized that just one
small planet isn't enough we need a very
widespread comprehensive solution
America ready for a green new deal I
think we are thank you her supporters go
further I think America is dying for a
green new deal
the corridors of power in Washington DC
are echoing with demands for change
these activists are from an influential
group called sunrise movement they want
Congress to embrace the principle of the
Greenlee deal even if for the moment its
light on details and heavy on ideals the
green New Deal is a massive
socio-economic mobilization at a scale
that the world has not seen since World
War two it will have to be a decade's
long project to tackle virtually every
sector of society from transportation to
buildings to power sectors and more
tackling the great the twin crises of
our lifetime economic inequality and
climate change in one fell swoop the
strategy supported by Ocasio Cortes is
maximum political pressure on everyone
this is a sitting at the office of House
speaker and powerful Democrat Nancy
Pelosi AOC said the climate Delayer is
the new climate denier caring about the
issue and wanting to do something about
it just isn't enough at this point and
young people are fed up we are fed up
with the generation above us that is
going full tilt towards condemning us to
a future that we cannot live in
political parties on either side of the
aisle have sold us out and we need to
see action commensurate with the scale
of the problem
[Music]
the message is getting through to the
Democratic presidential candidates and
party powerbrokers lining up against
Donald Trump
climate change is now a top issue
political futures depend on striking the
right
argent tone how important is climate
change to your agenda
it was my flagship issue s Speaker of
the House when I was there first and
it's still way up high on our agenda in
the house hurricanes wildfires mother
nature's join the conversation and you
can't deny that and all of a sudden
people are waking up to the reality this
is not a next generation reality this is
happening in real time
and they see the complete abject absence
of leadership by this current
administration that's just in complete
denial senator beau can you tell me how
important is climate change to your
policy it is central to all my other
policies it's got to be the number one
lens with which we look at everything
from Ag policy to trade policy it is
existential threat to the planet Earth
it's time for action this is our last
chance we need a president who will make
defeating climate change the number one
party a priority for the United States I
intend to do that and create eight
million jobs it's the destiny of the
greatest country on Earth that's America
you good okay be careful the urgency of
democratic activism feels a world away
in Oklahoma a deeply conservative
Heartland state suffering through record
floods emergency worker Doug hunter
takes us out to see the worst of it
within about 24 hours total farming is
the business around here but wheat
fields have turned to lakes and animals
have perished
[Music]
it's hard to connect specific weather
events directly to climate change but
scientists say that global warming means
they're becoming more frequent and more
severe May was the second wettest month
on record in America and for many what's
happening in the Midwest is evidence of
our changing planet this year has been
extraordinary I mean so in the midst of
all of this over the weekend we had
tornadoes everywhere and it's just been
very strange and we're you know we're
still facing next week we've got like
four days of rain and climate change how
of course I do I do yes you say that
like lots of people you know don't think
it's climate change I would perhaps say
that that's possible that's partly
because this region relies heavily on
the fossil fuel industry many here
regard the idea of climate change with
suspicion there has always been some
kind of climate change it moves around
the world and so there's probably no
question there something happened but
you know we'll see I'm sure there'll be
a lot of experts pontificating on what
happened don't have anything to do with
the co2 it's not Latin here because
that's been proven that that's happened
hundreds of times in the past so you
don't necessarily think that climate
change is related to human activity
still even here in the Bible Belt some
are coming to uncomfortable conclusions
do you worry that all of this might be
related to climate change and that it
could get worse for people who live in
communities like this one I'm gonna say
yes even though on the Republican you
know my Republican Party says you know
really much leadership denying this but
it's obvious if you pay attention if you
want to be blind to it you know go ahead
but do you want to just be honest about
yeah the climate change has affected
this whole world with no consensus
amongst his face Donald Trump is on safe
ground when he denies the role humans
play in climate change
he thinks the green New Deal is a
socialist fantasy that threatens the
fossil fuel industry he came to office
pledging to protect the so-called green
New Deal their plan is estimated to cost
our economy nearly 100 trillion dollars
a number unthinkable I will not stand
for it we will defend the environment
but we will also defend American
sovereignty American prosperity and we
will defend American jobs under Donald
Trump climate deniers have had a real
influence on government policy thank you
this is the man hired to oversee the
administration's transition period at
the Environmental Protection Agency
Myron evil has been described by
campaigners as a climate criminal there
is an alternative to the global warming
agenda it's called the Trump energy
dominance agenda and it is working in
the United States is now the world's
largest producer of oil and natural gas
and we are starting to export it after
decades of importing more and more oil
we're now exporting it should American
energy dominance come at the expense of
increasing global warming
making climate change worse and having
negative effects on public health global
warming it's not a crisis and it's not
likely to become a crisis the rate of
warming is modest the impacts are mild
there's life in the face of scientific
consensus no no III do not believe that
I think it it flies in the face of
mainstream media consensus gratitude
Berg has become a global icon of climate
activism but even as the ground swell of
voices demanding action
Rose she's worried about the mood in the
White House when you look at America and
hear what Donald Trump says about the
climate crisis what do you think I don't
really think because I I mean I don't
know how to react should you laugh or
should you cry I often love because it's
so absurd I think that among many other
things have proven that this this change
will not come from from the people at
the top so to speak it has to come from
movements from grassroots and that I
think is what we are trying to do
whatever the power of the grassroots
America is one of the world's biggest
polluters and without its leadership the
future is uncertain it feels like the
most powerful nation on earth is at a
crossroads on climate change and with an
election just around the corner the
choice facing voters is a stark one four
more years of Donald Trump and they'll
get a man who barely seems able to
acknowledge the scale of the crisis let
alone take action to tackle it and if a
Democrat wins they'll get someone from a
party that's increasingly embracing the
need for massive far-reaching even
radical mobilization in order to avert
an impending catastrophe
the day after the election will mark the
first opportunity for the u.s. to
formally withdraw from the Paris climate
agreement for those hoping to make
progress on climate change there
couldn't be more at stake
Hanna Thomas Peter sky news
[Music]